si vous croyez que le cannabis doit être
légalisée en francs non tout simplement
tout simplement parce que c'est la
première marche vers quelque chose qui
est épouvantable et je le dis et thierry
vous ne savez parfaitement bien j'ai un
frère qui est je connais votre frère
bien sûr qui est un homme parfaitement
intelligent s'appelle françois qui a
écrit des livres en marquant tout à fait
voir et qui a sa vie qui a été bouffé
par la drogue c'est messi est le
cannabis qu'il en est là où ils sont des
arts la prod je suis plutôt l'hérault
quand même soyons numéro après ouais
mais on ya plein de gens qui fument 99%
des gens qui fument du cannabis je dis
pas que vous en fumée mais ces gens là
ne vont pas forcément non c'est vrai
mais l'alcool le tabac et ses thermes a
pas tout interdire
ce qui est marrant c'est qu'on
m'interdit pas ce qui fait plaisir aux
viticulteurs français
c'est la seule chose qui lui est
conseillé recommandé par les médecins
sur cannabis mais bien sûr j'ai un ami
qui a pas les roses dans la salle trouve
qu'elle se lâche et le cannabis
[Musique]